willkommen zur seminar sitzung theorien
der existenz in der heutigen sitzung
werden wir pieter van in wegen und kidd
feiern behandelte sind gegenwärtige
analytische philosophen bevor wir aber
auf die näher eingehen möchte ich ein
rückblick geben wie immer
zusammenfassungen kurze über die letzte
sitzung wir hatten da auch zwei ganz
wichtige analytische philosophen
angelsächsische philosophen bertrand
russell und wird von rom und klein und
die sehen so aus das ist der rasse der
hat auch eine philosophie geschichte
geschrieben des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
dafür hat er glaube ich den nobelpreis
sogar gewonnen und das ist dieser
besagte herr klein der im jahr 2000
verstorben und klein hat ein aufsatz
geschrieben den wir uns jetzt in der
zusammenfassung immer genau anschauen
wollen
und zwar haben wir jetzt hier ein paar
fragen wie bestimmt klein existenz darum
geht es uns um seminar im anschluss an
russell und auch anfrage bestimmt qualen
die nichtexistenz ja auch immer ein ganz
spannendes thema wie verhält sich klein
zu kant und meinung das ist natürlich
dann interessant wenn es um nicht oder
unmögliche gegenstände geht das sind so
die fragen und der aufsatz mit dem wir
uns befasst hatten
der hieß an bord der iss also ganz kurz
auf deutsch was es gibt das ist nochmal
der kleinen und der aufsatz ist schon
recht alt von 948 ist aber ein ganz
klassischer aufsatz wirklich eine der
ganz bedeutenden aufsätze und das führt
mich zu einer nebenbemerkung die
angelsächsischen philosophinnen und
philosophen die schreiben nicht in der
regel nicht so große bücher wie es die
kontinentalen philosophinnen und
philosophen tun sondern die schreiben
häufig nicht immer aber häufig sehr
kurze prägnante aufsätze die dann aber
total einschlägig sind und die extrem
einflussreich wurden und dazu gehört
eben auch
dieser aufsatz was es gibt in diesem
aufsatz der wie gesagt 948 erschien
widmen sich klein dem und logischen
problemen und das problem ist einfach
die frage was gibt es die antwort darauf
ist eigentlich ganz einfach alles
natürlich ja alles was es gibt gibt es
diese aussage ist aber natürlich nicht
befriedigend sondern es ist natürlich
nur eine identität aussage es gibt was
es gibt wenn es was gibt und gibt es das
natürlich sehr klar
also das ist jetzt nicht so eine
spannende synthetische aussage habe man
kann ja unterscheiden zwischen
analytischen aussagen wie alle
junggesellen sind unverheiratet und
synthetischen auf aussagen wie zum
beispiel auf der erde leben
7 milliarden 7,7 milliarden menschen das
muss nicht notwendigerweise das sei aber
das ändert sich auch ständig und das
wäre jetzt also ein analytischer satz
hier
es gibt was es gibt jetzt sagt klein
erst mal okay nähern wir uns der frage
nach dem was es gibt über die andere
richtung an nämlich über die frage was
es nicht gibt und das haben wir schon
gesehen diesem seminar diese fragen nach
der nichtexistenz oder auch nach dem
nicht guten den bösen die sind der regel
viel spannender oder gleich über den
spannender aber über die können wir uns
häufig diesen problemen über umwege
besser annähern
und jetzt haben wir hier ein
paradebeispiel mit dem es immer wir zu
tun haben
auch in ganz verschiedenen theorien wenn
es um die nicht existenz geht das hier
ist natürlich pegasus und pegasus im
kampf gegen eine bestie und es gibt
natürlich auch noch andere formen von
pegasus es gibt auch noch pegasus kleine
große gibt es von allen möglichen
herstellern und jetzt wenn sich zwei
philosophinnen jetzt zum beispiel über
die frage streiten was es gibt und was
nicht dann stehen sie verfolgenden
problem
darauf macht qualm aufmerksam wenn die
person a behauptet dass das fabelwesen
pegasus existiert und person b dies
bestreitet dann muss person b zu geben
das pegasus irgendwie existiert
ansonsten könnten sich beide philosophin
oder philosophen nicht auf denselben
gegen stimmt beziehen
das wort pegasus wird von beiden gleich
verwendet muss also diese referenz haben
somit irgendwie existieren weil sonst
könnten wir uns ja gar nicht sinnvoll
über eine frage streiten über einen
gegenstand streiten wenn es die nicht
irgendwie gebe also wenn wir uns darauf
mit unseren worten unseren namen
bezeichnen beziehen können das ist so
das problem jetzt sagt klein dazu
folgendes nicht sein muss in irgendeinem
sinn sein was gäbe es sonst was es nicht
gibt diese dieser verwickelten lehre
könnte man den spitznamen plateaus art
geben glas und hat bart gehabt
wahrscheinlich also sie kennen alle
diese bildnisse von ihm in verschiedenen
kontexten aber wie existiert jetzt
dieser bat na ja wir können darüber
reden wir wissen alle was damit gemeint
ist aber gibt es intern auch und jetzt
sagt klein
es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten sich
die existenz von pegasus zu denken man
könnte picassos einmal als geistige idee
sich vorstellen das problem ist dann
allerdings dass wir uns pegasus wenn er
existiert immer körperlich vorstellen
wir denken dann ein pferd das eben
flügel hat und die geistige de von
pegasus die ist natürlich nicht
körperlich die ist ja wie gesagt geistig
man müsste sie dann noch daneben
existieren also ist ganz komisch und
eine weitere problematik ist wenn jetzt
pegasus wirklich existiert auch nur als
fiktion oder wie auch immer als geistig
idee da können wir dann pegasus ganz
eindeutig bestimmen kann spricht von der
durchgängigen bestimmbarkeit sprich
können wir sagen pegasus ist so und so
schwer wiegt
eine tonne oder wie schnell fliegt er
denn wie viele haare und wie viel federn
hatte das müsste man ja alles bestimmen
können wenn es ihn wirklich gibt das
heißt solche fiktiven gegenstände sind
irgendwie unter logisch unter bestimmt
diese nicht ganz vollständig und für
existenz scheint ist ein kriterium zu
sein dass etwas durchgängig bestimmt ist
das haben wir jetzt bei pegasus eben
nicht eine weitere möglichkeit sich
pegasus existieren zu denken könnte
darin bestehen pegasus existenz als
nicht aktualisierte möglichkeit zu zu
sprechen wie eine art prädikat na also
pegasus existiert demnach der
möglichkeit nach jedoch konsequenter
weise zb nicht der wirklichkeit nach
das wäre dann nur so eine eigenschaft
als der pegasus könnte wirklich
existieren er muss es aber nicht so wie
pegasus ein paar flügel mehr haben
könnte euro und ein paar federn mehr
haben könnte oder eben nicht
auch könnte man noch zwischen existenz
und subsistenz unterscheiden
das bietet sich auch an klein wendet
sich gegen inflationäre und theologien
wie etwa jene die über bloße mögliche
gegenstände diskutieren
das wäre nach klein eine über bevölkerte
welt sagt er
er spricht sogar von einem slum der
möglichkeiten also wenn es jetzt
mögliche dinge geben herr möglichen
pegasus dann denken sie weiter den
möglichen centaur den möglichen audi
sales alle möglichen fabel figuren
könnten sie dann annehmen sie könnten
alles annehmen um noch viel mehr als wir
schon haben
klein dagegen bevorzugt eine
wüstenlandschaft das heißt es im etat
verwüsten landschaft er möchte eine
sparsame und theologie gemäß dem prinzip
von orkans messer dass man andy täten
dinge nicht ohne notwendigkeit
vervielfältigen soll das lateinische
zitat was aus einer späteren zeit stammt
lang sind ja nun zum multiplikator
szenen zitat wörtlich dinge sollen nicht
vervielfältigt
ohne note es muss also immer grund dafür
geben dass wir jetzt etwas zusätzlich
annehmen
zu dem was bereits akzeptiert ist was
gängig ist
wir müssen das immer gut begründen und
sollten nicht ohne not neue dinge
postulieren sagt man auch noch häufig
werden auch in der physik bestimmte
entitäten postuliert sie kennen das bei
der teilchenphysik dass man sagt jetzt
gibt's atome und gibt es noch quarks
jetzt gibt es noch strings und war es
nicht alles man muss die gut begründen
und wenn man sie einführt müssen sie
einen mehrwert haben in der erklärungs
kraft sonst sollte man versuchen mit den
gängigen dingen das was man herausfinden
möchte zu erklären der islam der
möglichkeiten ist nach klein außerdem
noch eine brutstätte verdächtiger
elemente dann nehmen wir an eine
mögliche person iks mit der eigenschaft
a befindet sich an der raum ist dann
stellt sich die frage ob sie mit der
möglichen person w
die sich an derselben stelle befindet es
ermöglicht dass da an derselben stelle
eine person wie befinden sich befindet
aber andere eigenschaften als diese
person hat identisch ist inwiefern sind
mögliche dinge mit sich selbst identisch
sie sehen also wir bekommen große
probleme wenn wir von möglichen
gegenständen reden
und jetzt hat bertrand russell das ist
eine auf den sich qualifiziert der hat
im zusammenhang eine dieser fragen eine
theorie der kennzeichnung entwickelt
pegasus kennzeichnet ja etwas damit aber
die last des bezugs auf ein objekt davon
weggenommen
also wenn ich jetzt sage pegasus dann
hat dieser ausdruck die last des bezugs
auf nutzer also pegasus bezeichnet wird
was und das möchte jetzt und dann haben
wir das problem der eu dieser nicht
existierende dinge von dem kleinen am
anfang sprach
und das möchte jetzt rossel vermeiden
und er ersetzt solche kennzeichnungs
ausdrücke durch sogenannte
quantifizieren de wörter also das sind
letztendlich ausdrücke die man mit
kantoren versieht als es gibt etwas oder
nichts oder alles der kantoren und
dadurch muss jetzt nicht mehr der name
auf etwas referieren sollen dann es geht
einfach nur darum ob etwas unter diesen
existenz quandt urfeld als ob etwas eine
gebundene variable ist also mit dem auto
vom waverly war ein dichter kann demnach
re formuliert werden durch die gebundene
variable etwas schrieb waverly und war
ein dichter oder auch formale es gibt
nix für das gilt es schrieb valley und
es war ein dichter und logisch sieht das
so aus es gibt einiges das ixs schrieb
the valley und das ixs war ein dichter
die das dann eine praktisch sind
prädikate sie sehen hier ist jetzt nicht
mehr die rede davon dass wir es hier mit
einem kennzeichnungs ausdruck zu tun
haben der auf irgendwas referiert sind
hier geht es einfach darum ist diese six
hier dem diese prädikate zu kommen
schrieb webber ließ ein dichter ist das
gebunden durch diesen existenz quanto
ist eine gebundene variable oder nicht
damit ergeben sich diese probleme gar
nicht existieren und gegenstände nicht
als die last der referenz von der auto
von vivaldi wird übertragen auf es gibt
ein iks also auf die frage ob es eine
gebundene variable ist oder nicht und
nicht übertragen auf diesen
kennzeichnungs ausdruck dieses autors
das ist so dieser trick den russell
entwickelt hat und dem folgt auch klein
klein sagt wir brauchen uns nicht mehr
mit der täuschung zu quälen dass die
sinnhaftigkeit einer aussage die 1
deren ausdruck zum beispiel im pegasus
enthält eine entität voraussetzt deren
name jener ausdruck ist ein singulärer
ausdruck braucht kein name zusammensinkt
sinnvoll zu sein
ja und jetzt unterstellt eben klein den
anhängern der these dass pegasus
existieren muss weil die bezeichnung
pegasus einziehen hat da sie nicht klar
genug zwischen sinn und benannten
unterschieden haben also nachfrage eben
sinn und bedeutung klein sagt man
verwechselte den angeblichen genannten
gegenstand pegasus mit dem sinn des
wortes pegasus und schloss daher dass
picasso sein müsse damit das wort einen
sinn habe
daraus folgt nach klein dass wir
singuläre ausdrücke in signifikanter
weise in sätzen benutzen können ohne
dass es enten gibt welche jene ausdrücke
benehmen also wir können den namen
pegasus sinnvoll verwenden ohne dass es
dinge geben musste ein ding geben muss
was dadurch bezeichnet ist
wir gehen als und nach klein keine
unlogische verpflichtung das ist auch
ein ganz wichtiger termin der mit
kleinen verbindung steht ein über die
existenz eines gegenstandes wenn wir
singuläre ausdrücke wie pegasus sinnvoll
also bedeutungsvoll verwenden weil wir
eben auch zwischen sinn und bedeutung im
friesischen sind unterscheiden müssen
wir gehen unter logische pflicht um nur
dann ein
durch unseren gebrauch von gebundenen
variablen derart es gibt eine nix für
das gilt fx und diese einsicht die ihr
jetzt von rasse hat die fast klein
folgendermaßen zusammen als entität
vorausgesetzt zu werden heißt ganz
allein und einfach zu den werten einer
variablen gerechnet zu werden
das ist diese variable ist dieses es
gibt ein mix diese six der bereich der
variablen der quantifizierung etwas
nichts alle ist unsere ganze und logie
was immer sie auch sei und daraus folgt
nach klein eben auch ein ganz wichtiges
zitat zu zahlen heißt der wert
gebunden muss man auch dazusagen
variable zu sein
ja also es ist ein ziemlich normales
verständnis von existenz was uns
natürlich auch an friede erinnert ich
mach oben rechts und noch ein link rein
nachher im youtube-video zu dieser
stelle beim friege das sehen wir ganz
eindeutig hier haben wir es mit einem
sehr logische oder auch sprach
philosophischen verständnis von existenz
zu tun
martin heiliger zudem ich oben rechts
auch ein link reinmache der würde
natürlich sagen das hat auch mit
existenz nichts zu tun das ist doch nur
etwas was uns als gegenstände betrifft
also nur vorhanden sein oder zu handen
sein aber das was wirklich existenz
bedeutet nämlich dass da sein die
existentiellen das wird damit gar nicht
berührt das will jetzt wollte ich jetzt
nur als kontrast dazu bringen wir haben
es hier ganz klar mit einer analytischen
theorie zu tun wie sie vor allem im
angelsächsischen bereich aber auch immer
mehr content ahlen europa vertreten wird